[Music]
i remember the first girl
i courted i guess when i was 12 maybe
um it was at a lake that my family used
to spend a week at we used to rent a
cabin for a week and and the girl who
was staying in the cabin next door
i had a really big crush on and uh 11
year old me didn't know how to make a
move to the point where
when i was saying goodbye to her my
family started teasing me about oh you
should go over and say you know she's
like expecting you to say goodbye and i
remember
knowing that i should but not wanting to
do it in front of my family and so you
walked up to her car as they were
pulling out
knocked on the window right right and
gave her uh here's looking at you kid
right bogart move
well it was kind of like a little um
salute with my two fingers by my eyebrow
just kind of like i remember turning
around from her car and seeing you guys
and you were all trying to contain
yourselves and none of you were doing a
good job you didn't talk to a girl for
about 10 years after that
so mean it worked out sort of not really
um i'm single 41. anyway here's the show
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
and with me as always is my um
supportive yeah usually supportive not
then not then christian long um yeah you
i think we're just following
not to blame it all on my parents but
you were following their lead yeah and
at that age you're the youngest one
you're looking for reasons to
get some power and tease me and sure
and it was a perfect opportunity and and
in all of your defense
what it must have looked hilarious yeah
like embarrassment to the point of like
it's almost crippling i remember that um
like it almost prevented me from making
moves and every move i made toward her
car i remember
feeling like it was an accomplishment
you know like you know when you can hear
your heartbeat and it's it's the only
thing you can hear
going up to that car and like not having
a [ __ ] clue what to do what to say
what to do
to do it in front of her family in front
of my oh it's embarrassing so
embarrassing speaking of first crushes
is it fair to say that your first
movie crush was leah thompson our guest
today well i think leah thompson was my
first real meaningful movie crush like i
do remember being physically attracted
to carrie fisher in return of the jedi
so i know that's such a common thing i
never had a crush on adults when i was a
kid and to me
uh leah thompson carrie fisher they they
were grown-ups i liked girls
who were my age did you have a crush on
annie as i seem to recall or molly that
girl yeah but she was my age yeah yeah
she was a kid and third grade was the
first time i liked a girl in school but
i never i mean i i thought she was
pretty i'm sure you mean annie leah
thompson
but i never i never had a you know i
never like had a thing for her because
she was a grown-up i don't wanna this is
not gonna sound creepy if i
really get into the nuts and bolts
please don't really get into well
i just remember it was such an important
moment in my life like in so many ways
discovering back to the future was like
i can't overstate how important it was
in my development that movie like
wanting to emulate michael j i i thought
michael j fox i still think he that
character marty mcfly is the coolest
yeah he is the coolest that really had a
huge impact on you more than a lot of
people yeah to the point where you kind
of sound like i still kind of
yeah even that doc doc are you telling
me
my mom yeah but you're so i mean i st
i'm doing it right now with my hand i i
still
[Music]
gesture like he does um he it was it was
profoundly important to me that movie
and and of course leah thompson was
to me she was the most beautiful and it
didn't get any better and so it was very
difficult the challenge i faced was uh
in this interview was
somehow trying to separate because in a
lot of ways we've talked about this a
lot on the show like we're still our
childhood selves in a lot of ways yeah
but you met her for the first time a
couple years ago right or order well
longer
leah i met um when i was doing a show
called ed this is about 20 years ago now
um i was 20 early early 20s and the guys
who created the show
also really loved back to the future um
fetishized in a way that i did so they
had as many people from that show on as
possible they had thomas f wilson who
played biff they had christopher lloyd
uh
i can't wait to tell this christopher
lloyd story um when we hopefully have
christopher lloyd on
but uh and they had leah leah was did
several episodes and um
i remember at one of the rap parties uh
dancing with her we had a really fun
thing like an enchantment under the sea
it was enchantment under the sea jason i
would say
yeah but it was um
she is so fun and such an easy person to
be around uh and and despite my kind of
inability to hold back from like nerding
out around her and then years after that
we worked together on um
a movie that we talked about a couple
weeks ago called literally right before
aaron
leah played my mother in that which was
um and i know i said this a couple weeks
ago in the fran drescher episode but i i
think it bears repeating weird casting
yeah i get it for leah thompson
to play your mother the age thing is
just i couldn't get past it she's just
so much younger than
my mother
so sorry mom so if anyone has not seen
any of the three back to the future
movies
you definitely need to turn this off
right now and watch them yeah but she
was also she's been in some
other iconic movies like some kind of
wonderful and howard the duck which i
loved as a kid oh my god yeah she
married the director of kind of
wonderful howard the deutsch
i've been dying to make that joke
uh and she was on the show caroline in
the city uh it was the 90s right mid 90s
yeah right for like 100 episodes iconic
movies red dawn
she was uh space camp i did list goes on
uh i even loved jaws 3 when i was a kid
i i was obsessed with those jaws movies
we get into charles 3 a lot more than we
should probably
to me she's a nikon she um
she will forever be
uh somebody that there's a part of me
that will always kind of like love
i know that sounds weird
uh but she was like yeah like she was
beyond a childhood crush she was like a
childhood love yes it's like you had a
relationship yeah i did to say crush is
too fickle it's too late it's too
fleeting yeah yeah because i i never got
over it and every time i watch that
movie i um
i'm it's still
holds up more than holds up it still has
that uh
deep of an impact on me um
it's just i think it's the best movie
ever made and i think leah is just the
most
lovely wonderful
uh woman god ever made
and uh if you think that's gushy just
wait all the interview coming up next um
the sublime leah thompson life could be
a dream
i don't know if it's more flattering to
me or insulting to you that you played
my mother
i was
i was thrilled um
because as as i'm going to talk about i
i'll try to limit myself here uh
you i'm just a huge fan and and i
enormous fan uh to the point where it's
i've been pretty you know i've been
getting more comfortable with these
things and like talking to people and
i'm very i'm very nervous right now uh
but i
playing your son was surreal for many
reasons um
but but i think the thing that i was
struck most by was how how wrong the
casting was
and i was i told you this i know but i
didn't want to be too creepy about it
but first of all i am a huge fan of
yours you are amazing you are an amazing
actress we're cutting all this stuff
funny funny funny no don't cut that
you're awesome that means
i was honored to to be able to
be your scene partner you grew up in
minnesota in rochester yeah minnesota um
what what did your parents do what was
your family your upbringing like when i
was growing up in rochester my dad was
having a hard time selling life
insurance he wasn't very good at it
because he was
you know super uber honest
that's a no-no and my mom was an artist
like a painter and an
actress and she was unfulfilled and
so she was it was an interesting their
marriage was kind of falling apart my
mom was drinking too much and my dad was
drinking too much and it was it was kind
of a disaster but i had
four younger older brothers and sisters
that kind of co-parented me my older
sister is still my assistant colleen no
kidding did did they shelter you someone
from this dysfunction of your parents i
don't think there was much sheltering it
was a very i just went to visit the
house in rochester that i grew up in
want
and the rest of us slept in the basement
and my my would you have bunk beds yeah
we had army bunk beds oh my god those
metal army bunkers
and sheets
and but my brother's um scores for
scrabble were still etched yeah
you know that's so cool
it was really your parents one of them
lived there continued to live there no
we moved to minneapolis
you know it was easier to be poor back
then yeah we had we were very poor but
we had a beautiful house
like a block away from a lake in
minneapolis that they bought for like 13
000
so that was a kind of lovely and idyllic
and living by that lake so they stayed
together then no they divorced when i
was about eight eight my mom sobered up
and uh she died with 50 years in a.a
which was kind of impressive wow yeah
wait lee i'm sorry how were you then
able to get into the two-bedroom house
that you grew up in it was just a new
family live there and you asked
and i was
perturbed that they didn't know that
leah thompson lived there yeah right i
went to visit the other house in
minneapolis there should have been a
plaque there should have been a plaque
truly i'm not exaggerating something a
bust she had no idea at least one bust i
was like come on did she have a thick
mini sword accent was that an axe oh
yeah she had that so you know that's why
they let us in oh come on what was it
like did it bring up
memories that you know that had laid
dormant for a long and you know really
powerful yeah this recently i went to
give an award in minneapolis um and to
raise money for this theater that was
the first theater that i ever performed
in oh wow and uh then i went
this was the first time i went into the
next house that i lived in from the time
i was eight to the time i was 12 which
was really an amazing house and that
lady did know that okay all right she
had been told
so she gave us a very she's like where
have you been
knocking out a wall of houses around um
but she uh
that was very that was very powerful i
really cried a lot
because everyone's got you know my mom
and dad are gone so i'm like yeah god i
think that's why certain things are so
like uh this is us is so powerful the
idea of seeing time of course room in
different times oh my god of course i
i'm so struck by it i i um and that's
well that's why back to the future is
such a powerful story and that's why
it's connects with people because it's
about our you know ultimately it's about
our mortality and and
facing the the cruel hands of time right
like it's and what happened to you in
that movie it's interesting that you say
that about your mom was that
in in any way triggering playing
lorraine at an older age because in the
beginning the movie she does
it's clear she's drinking and playing it
did you think oh god i'm this is kind of
my mom no no my mom wasn't like that at
all she was a more she was a really much
more fun drunk okay
my mom was very you know she'd
ride around the lake and
jump in
hell she was a fun she was a good time
charlie yeah she was really fun she
wasn't like she wasn't like your uncles
that didn't make
for all again
okay she wasn't dowdy but
i did understand that character but i
based her on other people that i knew
the older lorraine oh really and you've
obviously never told them it's not about
um and this so then you're so eight to
12 you're in this new house and then at
what point do you start doing ballet
i would start a ballet when i was like
11. okay did you have ambitions to act
at that time or was it just ballet no
but i did my first play when i was 12 at
the at the children's theater which is
kind of of minneapolis which is like a
world renowned it won the tony a few
years like 10 years ago eight years ago
um it was a really amazing uh theater so
i did uh madeleine the gypsies when i
was 12. so that was my first play you so
you loved it you were this was what i
wanted to do no really still just wanted
to be a dancer i was actually loaned out
i was actually
like given by my ballet company to the
to the theater company because they owed
money
oh you were like
thompson to play the leading collateral
yeah i was like okay so and then it was
were you at abt because you joined abt
which is a very prestigious company um
were you there at this point no later i
went when you went to new york i went to
pennsylvania i was in the pennsylvania
ballet i was an apprentice there and i
didn't quite make it so then i went to
new york and i was in abt2
and uh and then i i it was funny because
then bursting off told me i was too
stocky and i was worked out and i became
an actor i became a waitress
okay i'll show you i'll become awake
wait tables do you think there's
anything worse for
a young woman's like self-image and
and um about female body image though is
there anything worse than the world of
ballet well no ballet is really
difficult but this is an interesting
thing that happened to me i i told you i
was giving an award or i was to misty
copeland oh sure
and she's the first uh principal dancer
that of color yes in abt so i was there
and i was talking to her and there were
i was at you know a reception and there
were all these abt head honchos and um
they were like you were an abt too and i
was like yeah you're right i was and
they were like you were such a i
remember you you were a beautiful dancer
i was like um i remember misha telling
me i was too stocky and like me quitting
dancing and they were like oh that misha
classic niche i've changed the course of
my life and they're like classic me i
just brushed it off but i was just so
thrilled that they even knew the story
and like someone had even pretended to
know that i was a dancer also i thank
god that he had that he did do that that
niche
thank god and that's what i say yeah
because that course in my life was
completely changed in that moment also i
mean
i think you i think it worked out and i
i mean that not only because of what
happened as an actress but but what
could have happened as a ballet dancer i
mean that's a life that
you know i wouldn't wish on anybody and
i didn't have the body i mean i never
you never went to the doctor but i had
when i finally was an actor and i had
the money to go to a doctor when they
x-rayed my back my last two vertebrae
thought they were part of my sacrum so
they didn't bend
so those extra two vertebrae that make
your legs go up in the back and like
make you i just kept thinking i was a
bad person
i'm like a mutant if i was a better
person i could get my leg up oh my god
my body of course and not not only with
the body image what the pressure that
that must do to a person that age really
unhealthy it is a beautiful thing yeah i
know it's beautiful to watch it's
beautiful to do yeah it's heaven do you
miss dancing you were on you recently
down you were on dancing with the stars
were you pissed you didn't win um no i
wasn't pissed i didn't win but it's they
should they definitely need like
12-step programs for people who have
been on dancing with this what what
happened it's just a freaking nightmare
all right what do you feel just like
immediate pressure it's insane oh i
would i would be i wouldn't make the
first round insane it's so much pressure
it's so insane producers with headsets
and like okay now you're up next there's
a lot of that like backstage
it's almost worse than that it's almost
like
oh really yeah it's almost like
now leah is making a very judgmental
face right now very smug yeah like they
like because they surprise you yeah and
they torture you and they decide where
the game is gonna go oh
you're a pawn yeah you're a pawn in a
game that so it feels like the hunger
games
literally feels like the hunger games
when you're in it oh my god well that
brings us back to abt hello
how do you quit as as what you were 18
19. i think i was at 20 20. 20 oh you
were old i was old
uh um i just were you crushed i was a
little bit crushed but i was all by
myself and i just remember going to my
locker and going that's it
that's it and i you know just took my
things and i just was like that's it i
got to do something else and and
and it was upsetting to me kind of as a
spiritual person i've always kind of
been a spiritual person and i was like
why would the
great spirit give me this desire to do
something and not just enough talent to
almost make it well he didn't say brutal
that's very yeah that's hard to wrap
your mind around sure but it wasn't
enough thankfully for you to not pursue
another
visual art
no no i didn't feel that way i i didn't
feel that way i felt ridiculous at the
time right because he's stocky
yeah let's face
facts says he dude yeah he's like short
right like why
he's not like life you know what i mean
it didn't it just felt ridiculous
because i was like 98 pounds i was there
was no way i was getting any skinnier i
think he probably meant that my hips
were too big or i wasn't tall enough
that they didn't clarify i mean
it was fine but but what it was was that
the the greatest dancer in the world was
saying i wasn't gonna make it so but it
was good i just was like that's it like
i gotta do something else you go wait
tables you're in new york now without
without any money no so
what are you thinking now
what's the next step it was very
interesting what happened after that i
was waiting tables and my
cousin
matthew berry who's now uh he was in
luna with bertolucci oh wow and my uncle
pj barry he was did a lot of commercials
and he was a playwright and they had an
agent
a manager who actually managed tom hanks
oh weird um
his name is sai maslow and i went to sai
maslow and sai maslow was like
and he sent me to sounds like such a
showbiz name
yeah i don't know but he also
was awesome because he sang at weddings
and and what was his name against sal
sal
wow really can't write that and he so he
he's saying on the weekends so he had
this like hi
boys
amazing
and the whole thing is creepy or it was
just like it sounds good teeny creepy
but nothing i couldn't handle sure so he
started saying he was known
no he started sending me out on
commercials which i got the very first
commercial i went out for oh wow
burger king burger burger king do you
remember what you had to do oh yeah well
because oh yeah nobody in new york they
couldn't they scoured the universe for
someone who could say aren't you
and hungry got i had that in my hip oh
yeah well you had been probably a little
hungry aren't you hungry
and the burger king was awesome because
they had the best casting director in
the history of casting directors because
there was actually a commercial with me
elizabeth shue
and sarah michelle gellar all in the
same commercial no kidding yeah they had
a good casting holy cow elizabeth and i
used to have to do the same commercial
they were such dicks
we would have to do the same commercial
they'd do a hundred takes with me then
they put her in and do a hundred takes
with her and be like he's the better one
oh my god i'm so annoyed with that that
we were like
we're not even gonna eat dinner here
we're gonna go across the mcdonald's
i'll show you
how quickly then did it lead to cha so
jaws 3d was your first
i love all the jaws movies but it's
obviously
it's not the first one
so but but it's a big job it's got to be
exciting to get because it's like still
at that point right that's like an event
movie of the summer
what i heard you lied about the
experience that you had as a movie
actress was that it i lied in my resume
oh okay well everyone does i lied in my
resume but the weird thing was that like
within two years of that being on my
resume they made both those movies that
i lied about
they were like wait a minute
you were in crossover i was like
no hold on did you just make up the
title i just made up the titles in the
movies in the whole [ __ ]
you're like sophie's choice
i was a bit psychic yeah wow and do you
lie about your water skiing experiences
oh yeah i lied that i could water skate
because there's this great sequence oh
yeah that's right
and you're doing a lot of sweet you're
playing a research no no
that's right best armstrong was the
researcher with dennis quaid yeah you
say you lied about swimming did that
make you then
nervous when you had to do that stuff
what gave you the confidence to
to do that was it confidence adjacent to
the ballet confidence yeah well i had to
do a three-tier pyramid
uh on on water that's right and then the
shark starts chasing you yeah so there's
six guys on the bottom two girls on each
of their shoulders and one girl on top
of each so it's two a double pyramid
on water skis and then you had we had to
put it on the ocean in order to make the
story work because orlando is not on the
ocean which is where we shot it and sea
world so we had to put that on the ocean
and where you shot where in oh you shot
in orlando orlando and that i think
that's why dennis quaid fell in love
with me because i was so awesomely butch
that i could do these crazy stunts
and not really know how to swim you know
because i had been a dancer i wasn't
afraid to do the stunts so they they
were smart they were smart to hire me
because no one else could have done that
right but back then you talked about
dennis quaid there wasn't like that
tabloid culture so were you able to be
in relationships without feeling any
sort of like scrutiny public scrutiny
well yeah i mean and he was kind of on
and off again famous um but he he did
really do a great job with teaching me
how to be
in hollywood and how to be an actor like
i didn't know anything i didn't know how
to handle money i didn't know how to
handle
work um you know it was
grim because he was married
he was married to pj sullivan oh that
little bugaboo oh i'm like a bad bad
child
don't ever do this on don't
don't do this at home uh so yeah it was
very hopefully your daughters stopped
listening after we shamed them uh yeah
no no no they they won't listen okay but
um but anyway they know this story okay
it's a grim story but uh it's it's well
listen you're young and people i mean
god if i could i'm so glad i'm not held
accountable for
so many things i did when i was that age
but also also it's dennis quaid you're
doing a movie with him and come on
whoever's judging this yeah let's see
you
not have a relationship with dennis
quaid
when
prime minister 21. yeah come on so still
got a washboard stomach yes even dennis
quite now i'd be hard-pressed not to
have an affair with
you and a few other folks yeah yeah um
but yeah he was a great guy and he
really taught me a lot about uh how to
how to sure how to avoid how to approach
acting how to um
how to
navigate hollywood were you enjoying it
i mean like with that experience that's
a big movie to do was it fun were you
just on a pure fun level and i was
scared because i didn't really know
anything i didn't know how to hit a mark
i didn't know anything so
i was scared but it was it was it was
nice because i had to just do these
stunts all day like my rehearsal period
was actually learning the ski world ski
show oh which was and i could still sing
come on down to the tug port holler
there's a feud going on and don't you
bother to bring your gun it's feud on
water twix hatfields and mccoys i
started too lower
how the [ __ ] you remember
who you are
really really high art but i learned the
whole you ran out of breath i learned
wow i did recently see that movie
probably maybe for the first time the
meg was coming out yes and they were
showing both of them uh-huh
oh at the theater in the theater so i
sat so i sat through the whole thing
what was that like did your kids had
your kids seen it no they haven't seen
hardly anything i've done what hardly
anything you're kidding mm-hmm zoey told
me she hasn't seen back future two get
out of here great movie yeah i almost
threw the microphone over
are you kidding me i know why are you is
that upset i didn't strap them down and
say what smile is moving
like clockwork orange style
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again so you're done all the
right moves yes i did all the right
moves that was the second movie i did
yeah
yeah yes yeah and it was jan's first
american movie wow it's beautifully shot
and kind of a precursor to friday night
lights for those of you who haven't seen
it it's about a steel town uh a very
working-class town in pennsylvania and
tom cruise uh all our moves is famous
because
tom and i were naked in it
and yes when dvds came out you could
stop it at the perfect point when we're
going in bed together and see his
i don't know about private parts i don't
know about it and everybody got really
excited about that uh-huh but the movie
is actually really really good right so
you didn't want to do the movie because
of that right i didn't want yeah i
didn't want to take my top off and was
it he that convinced you to no it he it
was he didn't have the part we both had
to screen test together oh really he had
done risky business but it wasn't gonna
come out okay
so he did outsiders and tabs and that's
yeah and he was also a little small to
play a football player right well he's
playing a defensive back so you kind of
buy it i mean he's still still smiling
yeah that's true
i think i think it was kind of i
remember doing my last audition in new
york with vincent spano oh
and then he and tom and i went they flew
me to la to do the screen tested fox
okay
and we were both really nervous i bet
had you met him before
no but he wasn't like tom cruise yeah
you were just nervous to be screen
tested yeah yeah yeah yeah and uh he was
great he he he has always been a really
great guy i think yeah i think he's just
he was always very polite and
you know real really worked hard and he
taught me all about music kind of
getting you into character he would
incessantly play
bruce springsteen in our honey wagon no
kidding i can see that
yeah you don't remember anything yeah
that's how he would get indicated really
oh that makes sense
and i and those great songs were just
coming out i mean born in the usa was i
think probably nebraska was just out so
yeah wow that was pop music that was how
cool then how does back to the future
come around oh so i do the wildlife with
eric stoltz and they're looking at him
on the chem which was this old thing
that that you had to watch movies on
while you're editing it
so they're looking at eric stultz and
and like apparently i need to read the
books
there's like 900 back to the future
so i don't i might know more you might
know
i've never read the book but
as far as i know they were like who's
that girl have her come in and audition
and um for some reason i just really
understood the character
i i i recently saw it's a very complex
character yeah i i really got that girl
and i i've seen
i've seen um interviews and stuff and i
was obviously defending myself in the
world because i was like talking like
this
all the time like i went to this weird
little place
i was like what do you mean in the movie
or no in real life
i was like wow so somehow
i figured out how to focus that
sexy kind of
little girl thing that i i was doing
with my voice
yeah it is weird yeah i wonder why i
wonder if it was a way to protect
yourself or i think so i think i was
just trying to be cute because it would
save me from having to know what i was
doing which is not fair oh she's
adorable
let's give her a pass yeah exactly yeah
that movie obviously is like and i and i
again i'm going to try to hold myself
back but um it's easily my favorite
movie and it's uh one that is so beloved
um universally for so many reasons but
what people i don't think give it enough
credit for is
is the acting i know that sounds kind of
like well duh yeah but i don't think
people consider that enough there's so
many like wonderful elements of that
movie and it just works in every way but
was the script was it like
was it
just diving into this script was it
easy to bring to life i mean you say you
work on it you worked on it a lot was it
um i've seen the script uh recently the
i found the script and i was like whoa
that's impressive like there was a lot
of you found your old school yeah my
back's future script and was it all
marked up oh yeah it was a lot of work i
did um
but because it is it is complex i mean
you're going from like you said playing
this
there's uh it's this sexy but
you also young sec like teenage you're
just becoming aware of sexuality and
then you're a a woman who's kind of
jaded and and and drinking too much i
mean there's so many goddamn meeting
with your son there's so many layers to
it well what was it daunting what i
think is i mean even when i was doing
those burger king commercials and
talking like um like
um i understood like i understood i was
i was a feminist
growing up i was very i had like a big
spiritual life i had a big political
life
and then i was bottled in this minnesota
girl right now people can see this way
and so i could see both sides i could
see
also as a dancer i was a modern dancer
yeah you know i wasn't just like mickey
i was like
yeah there was a sexuality in that yeah
i grew up with this like you're giving
birth
you know this kind of like so i wish
people would see this you're doing an
interpreter you're doing a modern
version but very it's very open and
fluid and it's sexual sexual yeah yeah
so i i understood the dichotomy the
right the
the and even when i did my burger king
commercials i'd be like
at burger king you we have some good
news and some not so good news do you
want a juicy whopper and a fresh pickle
i know exactly what
they were selling
can we uh get the ac going on i was i
would joke about it
but i understood it and so i understood
the sexuality and the play
in the 50s i understood and i did a lot
of work trying to understand
to speak my point of view about the 50s
and what it did to women after the war
and the stupid i read all these
magazines that were so stupid and i
understood it it was just like you know
you know it was my house in the 40s like
douche with lysol and then your husband
will love you
horrible stuff like that like if he
doesn't love you you need to clean more
and you know you know all this crazy
stuff get a new blender and you'll have
better sex it was insane it was insane
and you guys get to comment on that and
shine a light on how insane it is the
propaganda was so and i i had stacks of
those magazines that i read
to just get myself and and then i would
like sing mr sandman all the time and
listen to the craziness yeah
to get into character but sure you're
right the actors were really good and we
were all doing really really big
big characters yeah yeah but still
grounded all grounded
yeah and the thing that i'm really most
proud about
is like well first of all chrisman
glover was so
genius
i mean that just doing that laugh and
with the the cuts in that movie but
that's a bold choice and then you come
in with a yeah you know and you're like
it's [ __ ] brave
everybody was brave everyone was out
there and yeah
they were it was it was almost like up
for me now that i look at it it's almost
like a kind of like a education in
comedy styles
everyone had a different style and what
happened was when eric solz was in it he
he was doing he was doing marty and how
long did he film for six weeks six weeks
how did you feel then when he
not only is he leaving this person
you've presumably come to know uh but
all your stuff has to be all these six
weeks of your stuff has to be reached
was that they left some of the shots oh
right they left some close-ups and stuff
that was annoying and the whole
skateboard scene
when with the manure and all that you
they don't explain why all of a sudden
a wilds and michael fox has this
different kind of costume on and
slicked back
dark hair
they did that to keep and a stuntman
that doesn't look like him they kept all
the stunts the point being is that eric
sults was a great actor but she was
doing a style that wasn't uh
wasn't compatible yeah he was trying to
make a more natural
uh film and they had wanted monkey g fox
at the beginning at the outset in any
way and this was a more he had a more
it's to say sitcom style is sounds
insulting what i feel like michael did
his style was more like buster keaton
yeah he he like drew from the song book
of comedy the spit takes the falls
double takes that spit take is just gene
jesus you smoke too it's one of the best
one of the best and the voice cracking
and yeah all the stick he did yeah and
he planned every single shot like really
kick the skateboard off yeah how you
unlock the door and highest light across
the car and well that's from
multi-camera i'm sure right yeah you
don't think i feel like he got that
stuff from deeper into the song but yeah
you know like deep chaplain
chaplin and all those people and he
wasn't afraid to do that and a lot of
actors would be afraid well i hold him
in the in as high as steam as i hold
those guys so i wouldn't surprise me you
steal from the best right i mean
he's the reason i wanted to be an actor
i'm trying to i've stolen so many things
from him
he's great and but it was a different
style yeah yeah it was a different style
than i was doing it was a different
style than chris chrisman was doing
comedian dal art yes he was like almost
like a puppet he did all these weird
things
hey
yeah
hey you it's very
yeah his body even he's like a
puppety that's a good point he was a
genius genius what was that and same
with tom wilson yeah let me talk about
how great you are yeah yeah
yeah as biff and again
big hey mcfly i mean he's big and he's
this fight presence but real how much
that was direction too i mean would
zemeckis really encourage you to go for
it zemeckis was
i think he and that whole era
unfortunately are a little bit afraid of
actors but um
i don't know why i don't think we're
that scary but
i think that
he would just say like louder
yeah
louder
he did you know they they cast it really
well they cast everybody
and just just set you know commitment
see this is what i think about acting
right now i when i watch acting and i'm
directing a lot now and when i'm talking
to actors i just i just want to say
deepen it just deepen it don't you don't
have to do anything but deepen it like
go to the next level and does that mean
more pr
feel it a little more like sit with it a
little bit more yeah like don't just be
just don't yell at me find a reason to
yell at me i'm hurt
i i i need something from you i'm i feel
depressed you know just just totally so
many actors are just like on top of the
thing yeah but we deep we we were to
deepen every single thing bob's americas
knew that so many
massive plot points
rested on our acting right like when i
rehearsed i remember him being so
nervous about the kiss scene when i go
when i go it's like kissing my brother
yeah because he knew that i had to be
like
and then like
completely change into another person
and it is that's a good example of
something that a pivot that you have to
make as an actor to go from you want
this guy so badly to go from you you're
overcome with you know
and then right away
it's like kissing my brother
are you is that a scary scene to get
into is that when you can tell they're
scared yeah
and then but you know
crispin
you know after he punches him and he
goes
you know and for us to have to like are
you okay fall in love in one shot oh my
god of course it's like so
but they gave us the great music and the
great light i mean the the way they lit
me yeah it's beautiful did you get the
sense while you were doing back to the
future was there i mean i'm sure you've
been asked this a thousand times and
it's probably hard to answer but was
there any sense of course spielberg was
involved and zemeckis had done
you know big movies but did you get a
sense that this would be a game changer
certainly not that it would last there
would be comic con there'd be
conventions about it one day but like
do you are you thinking while you're
doing it [ __ ] this is this is a shot i
think i was thinking as a great part i
knew that it was a great part uh to be
able to play those different levels and
i think it would you know
i could
it established that i was actually an
actress like
a good actress and uh so no matter what
through my career once people want to
put me down i can go no dude you look at
this i played this part yeah this is
really good this is uh this is integral
to cinema history so go [ __ ] yourself
yeah and it wasn't just like i was the
girlfriend like it was twisted and
demented too which i appreciated
yeah just
um and that's part of its endurance too
i think is that people you know there is
that element too that's like pretty
[ __ ] up
when you unpack it
um
maybe that's why your daughters haven't
seen the second and third one
yes well yeah that's probably it i've
done i've kissed a lot of frogs and
stuff yeah and uh done done a lot they
they get very upset when i kiss other
people they did when i was young my did
when my my mom did an entrance
commercial once and i remember the kids
t she was in bed with a guy another guy
not my dad and they were dreaming about
apple strudel or whatever you know and
then they get like oh but it's raining
out i really want to go to the store and
then they you cut to her running outside
in in the rain and the kids at school
were um they were like haha i saw your
mom in bed you know on tv in bed with a
guy and i didn't get you know such a
late bloomer i didn't get what i didn't
understand why and a couple years later
i realized oh they were teasing me about
you know her being with some other guy
uh
oh my god yeah it's so sad now it was my
kids used to both like burst into tears
because they were really little when i
was doing caroline in the city and it
was you know guy of the week there was
always a news
caroline can't figure it out no she's
just uh
she's yeah all over the map yeah so they
it was always kissing a different guy
and they'd be like ah
oh no well no wonder they only saw one
episode of that yeah right after back
the future you alluded to this earlier
you did howard the duck which
at the time was a box office failure but
has now has since
gained cult status i think it's a really
good movie it's a really fun movie to
the point where you know they're
remaking it
do you know you know no they're yeah
kevin's doing this yo maybe kevin made
it oh okay all right
okay he's animating it well still i'm
trying to get i'm i'm i'm trying i've
went and pitched marvel a different
version of how
yeah they're doing all these comedy so
that at the time was like a dark horse
uh underground comic right yeah but it
was it was supposed to be it's your move
after back to the future so you must be
thinking this is like
everybody wanted the part i got to play
a rock star
george lucas you were like
yeah and it was uh it was um
you know a big universal movie
and
and uh was it
you know it still made 48 million
dollars wow and at the time that's
pretty that made its money back yeah
it's not the big bomb
it was a definitely a critical
failure but uh
it wasn't this like flop that people no
no no at the time i think
my boyfriend dennis had a movie i think
called enemy mind that this is dennis
leary dennis quake all right
i think it was it was called enemy mine
and i think that movie cost the same
amount and made like zero dollars like
that's a real bomb that's a bomb
did you guys talk about that
i'm still surprised because i looked it
up and it made like 40 yeah
that's a lot of money it was to the
point where it was remembered years
later i mean it's um
they just released it in blu-ray yeah
well it's a good movie they don't do it
if no one's watching exactly exactly so
take that enemy mine
take that tennis court everyone no i
know i have no problem with that quaid
family yeah
i have no problem with dennis it's just
that it's it's so malign and actually at
a certain point i got so sick of it you
know people going like doing interviews
and being like i'm
i have to ask you about howard the day
and i was like oh [ __ ] you and because
so many people i wish i had said it that
way
i have to ask you about how are they i'm
sorry but i have that okay my producer
would be so mad if i didn't ask sorry oh
you know
as if i'm gonna shrink away yes i'd be
shamed i'm at the comic con yeah you
know and people you got your finger on
the nerd pulse i do i have my finger
directly on the nerd pulse and they love
howard the duck yeah yeah [ __ ] y'all so
take that non-nerd life could be a dream
sweetheart
now some kind of wonderful
this is post back to the future um
was that a script that everybody thought
oh this is going to be something special
did you know of howard deutsch
no i didn't but i did know of john
hughes and i always wanted to get in his
mind right you know
yeah yeah that was the in crowd you know
the brad pack or whatever yes that's
right and everybody wanted a john hughes
movie and he would never you know i
always auditioned for him i never got
them but it was an interesting story
because howie
wanted me for this is deutsch not the
duck
and he didn't direct howard the dog that
was willard hike
um howie wanted me for some kind of
wonderful and it was a different script
huh and i said no and then
howie
left the movie and martha coolidge took
over
and the script got rewritten and then
martha coolidge left and how he came
back do you remember why you didn't want
to do the first incarnation because it
was because i could tell that the other
part was better okay and i had howard
the duck coming out and you uh yeah
you were sad i was sad you didn't need
to go slam it with flowey deutsch no uh
so then howard the duck came out uh-huh
howard deutsch came back you're like let
me look at this amanda jones thingy
so when you're working with howard do
you is it right away do you like
you guys fall for each other it's just
no
i he had a crush on me
um
there's a painting in the movie that's a
that's a plot point yes and so we had
like 12 of them painted because none of
them were good enough so that's when i
knew he had a question wait a minute
crushed borderline that's a nice way of
saying what he had
but at this point still i was engaged to
dennis quaid oh oh wow you were with i
didn't you know
so uh so i i had to kind of get out of
that before i um
before uh right before but it was a
crazy time i mean i did like 900 movies
in a row god yeah how do you maintain
anything when you're working that's
crazy i did 900 movies in a row but what
happens is it all screeches to a halt
when you have a baby and this is i want
to do the research on this because
once you push a baby out yes you can't
be a movie star anymore
is that a scientific fact well let's do
the research uh-huh okay the only meryl
streep is the only one i was just
thinking of meryl streep yeah she pushed
a couple out yeah yeah you can adopt a
baby oh charlie and and halle berry and
sandra bullock that's an interesting
theory but once you push it once you
actually create a placenta you can't be
a movie star anymore they don't take
your sag card necessarily but but it's
the movie star card yeah it's like does
your face change that much or what
happened it's interesting i never did a
movie after that a starring role i did
the beverly hillbillies after that what
i have never done a big feature isn't
that crazy the beverly hillbillies
um you do back to the future two and
three at the same time yes that's in
like 89 yeah time and uh did when you're
doing that did michael did he know at
the time or this is a couple of years
later he found out about his diagnosis
it was later later i mean i don't know
when he did yeah yeah i don't know
according to his book that he was doing
doc
you've read the book i've read many of
the books i'm a big nerd i can't believe
i'm not at those conventions um
uh
so
interesting and do you at the time are
you is it frustrating it's like
what's going on i've done these i'm in
these big movies yeah that's so
frustrating yeah i i still can't believe
it but luckily there's tv
you do start doing tv in the early 90s
um and caroline in the city is a huge
hit what was that just a
did you miss doing movies or was it like
oh this is comfortable i'm raising kids
this is sweet
um i found sitcoms to be very very
traumatically hard really yeah i mean
not so much so as some other actresses
i've heard of that like threw up every
time but
it's very um in front of the live
audience
yeah you know just the
the process of
doing a live play every week right with
the pressure of like telling the jokes
like boom boom boom and not being able
to screw up because if you screw up
they're like get really mad at you
really oh you could do another take no
with multicam i don't know if you've
never done it i have and i definite
pressure because it wasn't my show and
i'm just coming in as a guest star but
you're an abt like talk about pressure
like that you can't mess up that's like
you got to be [ __ ] fearless to do
that so how does that person
how does that not kind of like transfer
over to
this sitcom you know some people have a
different experience i think my show was
first of all we had the best time slot
ever on tv between friends
thursday night between friends and er at
the peak of their their time or
yeah between er and friends so it was
literally the best time so ever
so that was a lot of pressure
on me and there was also this horrible
kind of sexist pressure
deserved or not deserved because
there was sybil there was roseanne and
there was one uh there was another show
mrs belvedere no with a woman
uh that sitcom's three sitcoms with
women that were veronica
no it was brett butler oh grace under
fire
yeah maybe and those those women were
very difficult all three of them very
difficult roseanne was oh
they were all very difficult
so they were trying to like kind of keep
a lid on me even though i was like the
nicest person ever i was like dude i
have already had a career yeah stop
being paranoid a nightmare don't project
your [ __ ] about these other people onto
me so they were like kept a real lid on
me and um
right yeah they were like you stay in
your place and uh so oh my gosh how
would that manifest itself um
it just just stay in your place just
stay in your lane and just do be you
know don't screw up uh don't misbehave
don't you know i had two little kids at
home so
but for me you know some people
experience sitcoms as being much easier
than i did it was it was a lot but i did
100 episodes of that god you got to be
proud of that yeah yeah yeah i love that
show these are quick these are just
going to be quick uh what's your
favorite emoji your go-to emoji tear
coming down
okay not gonna touch that but that's the
truth tear coming down your favorite
emoji
that is making me cry inside if you
could be a professional athlete what
sport would you play and why uh
be a skater figure skater is that a
professional yeah sure i think so figure
skaters make money doing
skype
so beautiful but tanya harding became a
big uh yeah yeah
um if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life what would it be
doritos which uh nacho or cool range
nacho okay you know
neil patrick harris said the same thing
and then he said i said what about cool
wrench he said oh no that makes your
breath stink i was like well nacho it's
not doesn't matter yeah
uh what's your favorite movie of all
time harold maude uh still yeah yeah
yeah oh wow i bet you're yeah okay well
uh cat stevens too i mean because he
talked about yes yes god
you mean yousef islam on this show we
say yusef islam out of respect
um other than l.a where would you most
want to live
atlanta oh montana do you guys go there
yes we have a little we have a double
wide oh wow i bet you don't have a
double wide i don't have i don't even
have a single wide a double wide well
where's your double wide is that it's in
private nice my double wide is by
flathead lake oh my god you fly fish
no
okay there's no trout in my river it's
all
walleyes
that's like some damn minnesotans
introduced them oh gosh they're invasive
don't you know they are invasive they
eat all the trout ipads and they
crawfish crawfish that's louisiana um
they did really is that true the walleye
but they're good eating they are good
they fight you yes yeah pick their pike
right pickerel they're real boney no
wallet no no
uh okay
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive who whom you've
never met before
that's a tough one yeah those are uh
three people yeah uh it would have to be
albert einstein william shakespeare and
barack obama oh my god second person in
a a lot of that's great i mean what a
great group someone said that group no
no no no no one said that but but uh
it was the second obama um who's your
favorite muppet uh
[Music]
my favorite muppet
uh probably cookie monster oh yeah yeah
yeah uh a cookie monster used to bother
me because
i couldn't understand why
only some of the
this is how young i was when i was
watching i thought why then the cookies
just kept falling out like you love
cookies so much most of them are falling
out of your mouth just pick them up oh
you're so preoccupied with talking about
how much you love cookies they're all
right in front of all these like big
crumbs not a real person you can't
really eat right i learned that about
two years ago
but i'm but i'm confused because uh
because
when i was pregnant with zoe who's my
second child i i told madeline that i
had i was really worried and i said
madeline i have a baby in my stomach and
she went oh that's zoey and i was like
what
and so later the next day i said so
who's coming she goes it's zoey zoey's
coming so i what
i know so my name is zoe
but we or she had the prophetic title
thing that you had when you were naming
fake fake you're patting your resume
exactly but i always wonder if she named
her after zoey the character on the
muppets there's a zoe character i did oh
a later one with red hair yeah yeah
oh my gosh but i don't know i don't know
i don't i so so she said that and you're
like oh zoey's a nice yeah he's such a
nice such a girl because a boy named zoe
would be rough it's like that scene back
to the future and you're like marty's
such a house uh zoey such an interesting
name such an interesting name yeah
uh if your parents ever if you ever have
a kid and one of them when he's eight
years old accidentally sets fire to the
living room rug
go easy on him
you're good okay um
uh uh believe me i'm gonna go it's a
good thing you don't have any more time
because i'm gonna it's uh if you could
be
one age for the rest of your life
physically
what would you pick 32 32. uh if uh uh
uh camping or glamping
camping um
dogs cats
dogs
um beetle stones
stones
really you were the second person who
answered
so emphatically oh i love the beat yeah
yeah yeah well you weren't as emphatic
as wolfgang puck said without missing a
beat stones as if he hated the beatles
oh yeah yeah uh that's our theories that
wolfgang puck hates the beatles um some
people do
who hates the people's [ __ ]
you gotta be you gotta be you gotta be a
soulless but i like rock and roll yeah
i like for some reason i just like like
makes me judge my heart
that's the kind of music i just like to
get like breezy like sexual because yeah
yeah that's the kind of chance i
remember dancing with you once at a
because we did ed together right and we
had a such a it
if you look under your seat i'm gonna
grab it for you this you you don't have
to do
you don't have to do and this is only to
satisfy
uh this is selfish
it's very selfish but this is a scene
where marty first meets laura i've
totally a shanghaied you here uh this is
a scene where marty meets lorraine uh as
a younger lorraine for the first time
and i was reading it today and it struck
me that a lot of you guys must have
definitely changed things
um
it or was it improvised and i want to
ask about like
certain lines like line by line if this
was if you remember this being i think
this is the original script
really um he wakes up and he says
mom
is that you
shh everything's gonna be all right
god what a horrible nightmare
i dreamt i went back way back in time
take it easy now
you're you've been asleep for almost
nine hours
it was terrible it was a terrible place
to be the now this is new right this is
all
i don't remember this this must have
been cut the music was awful they didn't
have rock the cars were ugly my
neighborhood hadn't been built yet and
everything was so weird looking
well you're safe and sound
back where you belong in good old 1955.
now you're 55.
oh my god you're my you're my you're my
mom my my name's lorraine yeah jane
baines yeah but you're so ah you're so
uh thin
just relax calvin you've got quite a
bruise on your head ah where are my
pants
over there it used to be on my hope too
yes on my hope chest maybe i made that
up i wondered i've never seen
red underwear before calvin now
obviously everyone knows
change i've signed a lot of purple
underwear oh really yeah sometimes on
no yes where on the band you gotta go
high as possible obviously yeah gross i
know uh yes they ch so i wonder if that
was a prop thing they didn't have red
underwear or calvin klein didn't make
red underwear i've never seen per yeah
because we now know
this was an interesting scene to do
because i had to kind of pretend to be
that voice you know oh in the beginning
yeah right i had to try to kind of as
he's coming out i had to be like when i
turned around i had to
it was it took a long time to get this
right
why are you calling me calvin oh my god
that's your name isn't it it's written
all over your underwear
um oh well that's your name calvin klein
it's written on your underwear this is
new right oh i guess people call you cal
no i said that i think you did yeah well
no actually people people usually call
me marty
well i'm pleased to meet you marty
oh
that's marty i think i said calvin oh
yes yeah well because marty calvin i
think you said this is a definitely a
scene that i shot with
with eric oh it is
like one of the first times i worked
with him
mind if i sit here no so now this is
different in the script it just says uh
no
gulp's nervous but of course we now know
he goes and then it's brilliant he goes
no good good great good good i mean it
goes on he's yeah
that's quite a bruise there ha and then
he fall yeah
lorraine are you up there
it's my mother
oh my god i always say oh my god your
pants back on originally it was his
underwear that were on
the whole i wonder if you may help chess
that's such a great one i think so i
think i i think i don't know no i think
see one of the things i loved about this
movie was how much joy bob zemeck has
had doing it oh you know what i mean how
much joy he had
what laughing and
that's what that's what i remember that
was so
profound to me how much i wanted to
please him how much
how much joy and how
fun it was to see his shots and how he
shot and it stuck with me as a director
his the way he filled up this
every single shot was story yeah you
know what i mean
every moment every element was important
for the story advanced yeah and when you
watch the movie it's really slow in the
beginning but yeah telling the audience
watch this stuff and pay off because
that cause that joke when i set it up
your uncle jailbird joey didn't make her
own yeah you need to see the cake you
need to remember the cake and the and
it's like 40 minutes later where the the
punch line is so you're my uncle joey
you better get used to these bars kid
that's right you're right that's that's
minutes from setup to joke wow that
again brilliant brilliant and brave
brave
do you think about things like legacy
and and
i think about the movies even my watch
old movies i've done it it's a good
reminder of like a time in my life that
it's it's nice to be reminded of do you
feel that do you think about things like
that like legacy and permanence
well i see it in real life when i see
these like little kids that are like
what's really nice is doing these panels
because i've been doing panel with chris
lloyd and michael fox and tom wilson and
so
what's great is that we don't have any
problems with each other yeah we all
still love each other there's no problem
and i could cry it makes me so happy i
we just laugh and you should see tom and
chris together i wish they would
televise some i know because they're so
funny i know well lately we've been
doing with james tolkien who played the
the principal oh sure oh sure
jesus didn't that guy ever have hair
he loves the scent he does really so
does chris yeah yeah well again because
chris was an older there was an older
version of him they aged him and they're
doing a musical now um so yes they're
doing a musical
so i think you know all the people who
want back to feature four they might get
the musical musical movie uh when i
worked with christopher lloyd did an
episode of ad i bugged the [ __ ] out of
him i i really restrained myself with
you if you can believe it that was me
restrained when we worked together i was
like i waited till you know we had been
working for a little bit but christopher
i just like followed him around and at
one point i remember him saying
gigawatt i don't remember the line one
point i don't know and he kind of gave
up on um
on somebody but he 100 has not read any
of the books he doesn't remember
anything
it must be so weird to him that people
show up i know yeah but they do because
it's it's a again it's a part of our
lives and it's such an important part of
my life and so i mean if you had told
seven-year-old me that i would be
talking to you about this and i wrote i
mean i roped you into doing the scene
his seven-year-old little head would
explode so i i can't thank you enough
for doing this i didn't do it very well
i wouldn't cast me as lorraine i i i
surprised you i put you on the spot and
um
i stepped on one of your lines too it's
like i'm going to talk about
regrets i'm going to be thinking about
that for this
you're the best and they say don't meet
your heroes you know and i'm so glad
when i met you we worked together i'm so
glad you turned out to be as kind as you
are and um i really i'm liking her
i thank you so much i'm so glad
barranchikov told you you were stocky
thank you thanks
miesh thank you for having me thanks
this was a thrill and uh thank you
doc so that happened
oh my god ah so that happened
i think over the course of that
interview
you may have said every single line in
back to the future
i mean obviously all out of order and
out of context i
but you got most of them you know when i
roped her into doing that scene it when
it when it was happening it didn't
register as being as embarrassing as it
was when i heard it back oh really yeah
i mean i was embarrassed but
hearing it back like uh because it had
been
we i think we got into a really
comfortable groove with one another and
and then to like i broke it and was like
um under your seat you'll find that
sometimes that was kind of nerdy but you
know i
i obviously
knew what a thrill that was for you so i
enjoyed listening to that but you know i
think in the show there's a pretty good
balance i would say of
uh
what we get from it and hopefully what
an audience gets from it the show that
is yeah and
that that you asking her to read that i
think was an example of
like
that was for you you know what i mean
but i do think i do think uh it was
still really fun to listen to but it was
like that was for you that was a little
but that but i'm glad you got to do that
i i am that must have been such a thrill
as selfish as it was and and i i agree
with you i think that probably was uh i
don't know if it alienated people but it
probably wasn't the most entertaining
thing no it totally was that but your
intention
was not entertaining no your intention
was to do something that the
eight-year-old version of you yeah would
have loved to do yeah and it but it
ended up being entertaining for me it
was good i because i
it's one it was one of the best moments
of you know those moments that you'll
remember that
just surreal yeah oh just hearing her
voice i yeah i did i wasn't there so i
didn't get to meet her sadly but um
so i just
listened to it back and
hearing her voice was so strange because
there's something so familiar
about it to me because i've seen that
movie so many times and and it's so warm
and loving and i thought there's comfort
it's comforting yes and i thought uh you
know when
she plays the old
version like middle-aged lorraine yeah
uh in back to the future she hannah sort
of like
boozy
kind of sad quality towards my uncle
didn't make parole again but
but her voice now
sounds so much more like young lorraine
yeah he does than middle age it must be
strange for her to have seen the old a
potential older version of herself well
it's also a credit to her performance
yeah that yeah that she made that was a
real uh choice that voice i never
thought about that in that scene the
scene that we did um
how
what an acting challenge that must have
been to go from old lorraine because you
needed to be tricked by the voice you
know that like older voice and then
he'll he wakes up and he's you're my mom
i mean yeah and then it's like the young
version of her that the whole part i
mean she talks about it a lot thankfully
that but what a challenge
that was it you know as much as
obviously everyone knows i love the
movie understatement um i it never
really occurred to me until i talked to
her
what a huge uh challenge that must have
been what it would have yeah difficult
role uh all of those parts i mean the
first few minutes of the interview you
were
i mean no surprise
you came across as very giddy
and nervous and
so consequently i think you steamrolled
her a little bit
at first but then
you definitely uh eased into it you
relaxed into it i mean i know how you
how excited you were so it's actually
yeah it was actually restrained yeah for
what it could have been yeah i yeah
it could have been a lot weirder and
i you know you know why i think because
i had already we'd already worked
together and right i think had it not
been for the fact that we we worked
together for a
spent a couple days with one another and
she
had some insight into what a fan i was
when i
i also wrote her into doing this video
bit for it i put on instagram i got to
put it on instagram and you've been
showing up at her house a lot lately so
she's just used to seeing you he's a
peeping tom
oh that's one line you didn't get to no
no now you did now you did the whole
thing okay
we're lorraine another one of those kids
got in front of my car again
uh that story that barishenkov story is
crazy crazy said she's too stocky but
thank god i agree when you said that
you're like i'm so glad he told you
you're too stocked oh thank god god he's
thank god he was uh whatever you would
call someone who would call her a stocky
not a misogynist just a body shamer yeah
i mean that's that whole that looks
better no he's not a misogynist he's a
body shamer
i mean that whole it might be both but
it's you know it's remarkable that
getting that gut punch from that guy i
know and then she was able to pick it
into pieces and keep her down
i i would have folded we've talked about
this a lot like that they're the
resiliency sure people is so impressive
that yeah and i think you kind of need
some of that in order to
make it where they've made it i mean
there's something that's why i i you
know i wish i had asked her this now but
i i wonder if she um hesitated to
encourage her kids to get into acting
just knowing
you know how fraught with rejection it
is and how she although once she did
become an actress i know she waited
tables for a while but it sounded like
things started happening pretty quickly
yeah and you think how could they not i
mean
she's she downplays this a lot but like
she is
a really talented actress i mean she's a
real
real and she then she just was such a
charming
screen i don't want to get into it yeah
i've done enough um i love when she
slips into her minnesota accent and
i love that accent i've always loved
that accent have you ever been to
minnesota minneapolis uh i have it's
great stay in edina which is uh
don't you know oh sure it is a suburb of
minnesota
it's a yeah i love minnesota me too
harmar
harvard who does our uh
theme music yeah the show is
famous in minnesota yes in fact he named
himself after a mall the harmar mall
right yeah uh um i love but i love the
accent i love how you uh obviously copy
it instinctively like you do with all
the guests when they have a cute accent
is it condescending to say i almost i
was wondering that i don't know maybe to
say it's cute about some about an elder
is it she's patronizing she's an elder
well she's she's older than me she's
older but to say an elder she's not
saying she's like a tribal elder
she's elder than me i'm not saying she's
old no i know i know it's sticky though
it is sticky um yeah cute it is i i find
it patronizing and this doesn't apply to
her but i find it patronizing in general
when people refer to really old people
as me too he's like i think yoda is cute
i think most people would agree that
yoda is cute but yoda's a fictional
character no i know i know but i'm
thinking
that's the thing i do think old a lot of
old people are cute like i would
internally describe them that way i
would never say it
because i think that it's just something
condescending about that remember when
we met uh i had met him but danny devito
he he was he was cute
but i wouldn't say that to him no i i
would be i think it'd be rude
uh when she told her when she told you
that her daughter sean is cute too i
wouldn't say that to him either i know
uh when she said that her daughter
hasn't seen back the future too i
thought your head was gonna explode i i
thought you're gonna start throwing
equipment
your voice became distant for a second
and you were like what
what
what's really funny
i got really incredulous i got
not mad i was just stunned it was it's
like
i don't know it's like julia roberts kid
not having seen pretty woman like i
haven't seen pretty woman but i'm julie
roberts
um
but i only say that because i've gotten
so much [ __ ] over the years for not
having seen that movie that's like
wouldn't you say pretty woman is the one
movie that people are always like you've
never seen
that's one constantly constantly i
should just see it but you know now it's
sort of like a badge of honor that i
haven't seen it yeah i'm like proud that
i haven't seen it you know dirty dancing
is like that for me a little bit you've
never seen that no see no i'm not mad at
you there's a tinge of judgment um i
can't believe how casually she admitted
to having an affair with dennis quaid i
know and uh your reaction to it was
really funny like not only did you
approve of it but you were encouraged
you were like oh i mean dennis gwade
like are you kidding me he's gorgeous
well he's not flat abs not to talk more
about looks but like i also fetishized
his looks he was he was the coolest he
was so inner space dennis quite an inner
space okay
if you guys haven't seen the movie inner
space with martin short meg ryan
uh like uh uh in her prime like such a
charming performance if you're a
superficial person and you've never seen
that movie and you like comedy you are
waste you've wasted a lot of time i i
know we said this in the beginning about
back to the future but i wouldn't say
stop the beginning of this episode of
the inner space but stop it now and
watch inner space oh my god it's good
uh you were very pro affair with dennis
quaid
um
well also then i mean then i felt
yeah i mean that's superficial i i and
this show is exposing among other things
i think good you know i think it's
exposing that i do maybe have a problem
with superficially with good looking
guys yes yes
uh well at least we're talking about
dennis quaid and not tom brady that's
true researching the character and
working on the character of lorraine
because
i i never realized i mean not only how
complex it was but she talks about being
a feminist and sort of a complex person
yeah but also from you know a small town
in minnesota and so so is this dichotomy
that she happened to have ballerina
exactly so i think she
part of it is luck i guess she had
the this duality to her personality
which you need to have to play that part
and they're to play like because it's
like sexy and like kind of vampy and
adult but also super innocent and 50s
exactly she had to have some uh
understanding of the misogyny of the
time she mentions this uh
that kind of like housewife misogyny uh
that was so a part of the fabric of
those times like like it was just
it's just how it was um
and and she was because she was
commenting on that in in such a subtle
like real way with that performance um
and it's something that's another thing
i never as as well as i know that movie
it's something else i had never really
considered
is uh that
and another
another reason to love that performance
yeah i thought it was insane what she
said but i believed her completely about
what she said about once you have a baby
she said once you push a baby out uh you
can't be a movie star anymore and you
and you start thinking about it and it's
so [ __ ] up well you know that there
there is truth to that absolutely and
i've been thinking about it since she
said that uh which is now several months
ago
um and i've been talking about that to
people
not just actor friends of mine but
trying to find examples where it's it is
not true um that when you have a baby
you can continue to be a movie star and
i think actually with her generation uh
it's been much more true than it is now
hopefully things are changing somewhat i
think they are so i mean like scarlett
johansson that's true they're people
that's
definitely that's true that oh that's
true i'm thinking of a very good friend
of mine alison lohmann who is one of the
best actresses i know we did drag me to
hell together she was that she was all
set to be you know she could have had
her pick of any script in hollywood she
had
two kids and
i had a very
difficult time even you know breaking
back that's so unfair it's unfair uh it
is really unfair but i mean there the
examples that i can think of are they
were so famous before yeah
i mean leah tom
it's hard to fathom going from
her performance in back to the future
and how big of a i know of a franchise
that was to go from that
to unless she like murdered somebody
to go from that to having a hard time
getting a movie it's it's hard to wrap
your head around it is and she and she
remained you know it's not like she'd
lost her
look no and she proved herself to be a
really good actress with with that
future
i also wonder if
maybe she was also a victim of the
success of
back to the future in that maybe i think
sometimes when someone is so identified
yeah as like a character in this case
lorraine and back to the future
maybe it's hard for people to see her in
other roles i don't know you know i was
thinking that when i was watching
airplane the other day and robert hayes
who was the star of airplanes like god
this guy is
really good looking and he got a great
comedic timing and he's go so good in
those that those two movies airplane
movies and he he didn't do much he has
like a john ritter quality um
and he didn't do much yeah the same with
julie haggerty and those but those were
huge movies and i wonder if you may be
right that like they just couldn't
escape that role but leah does mention
that he she made i think that's why
howard the duck is
sort of a
frustrating thing for her now because uh
i i think that that was considered like
kind of a
she talks about it it was a bomb and she
says that it made money but critically
it was a bomb correctly why should she
suffer that much even if i agree critics
hated the movie she was good in it i
agree and i mean i thought the movie was
really good i granted i haven't seen it
since i was a kid but yeah i loved it
yeah i it never made sense to me that
that movie
didn't get good reviews and then she
made casual sex which i only know i know
i could tell you i could probably if the
box cover of that movie committed a
crime i could draw the best police
sketch of it i know it but i've never
seen the movie oh really never seen it
but uh when i was a kid i was so you
know maybe i've talked about how i felt
about leah thompson and then the fact
that there was sex in the title
i know it well it's so funny why the
cookie monster bothers you because
yeah you don't like that he doesn't get
all the cookies in his mouth yeah but it
is ridiculous i think he gets less than
half of the cookies in his mouth when he
eats wait a minute you're you're joking
much less than half
you're kidding he gets none oh okay oh
that's probably good
i got like nervous you thought i thought
you thought i thought the cookie monster
was a real like maybe there was a hole
in the fab the felt or something no i
thought you'd be afraid that like it's
based on a real character oh maybe i'm
maybe i'm too hungry i know it's a
muppet oh man maybe i need to eat some
food
but it's funny that that bothered you
yeah yeah yeah that you were stupid as a
kid and didn't realize there was a
muppet i believed in the easter bunny
until i was in sixth grade the easter
bunny still exists right right i
believed in uh
um so again thank you mikhail brishnikov
yeah shout out to mish yes it's funny
because we call our producer michelle
lansmish and um so misha's now
but she doesn't body shame people no and
she also doesn't like create a k in the
chaos effect of somebody's life she
doesn't create movie stars because if
they're shaming
[Laughter]
not yet and no or maybe maybe she does
uh yeah thanks me she thinks uh
barishnikov is he's passed on right no
no no he's very much alive really yeah
you're kidding brishnikov that's oh yeah
he's still he's still oh he helped train
sam for uh bossy version
i think so i think i remember him saying
that or he met or he met him in the
process or something wow oh he's very
alive he's like really healthy like are
you saying he's like really viral no but
he's
very active i think he still acts and he
you're kidding using sex in the city you
know
oh
i think i did i'm proud to say i i
didn't have that immediately accessible
but um um so do you want to should we
read a uh yeah so we're gonna uh
close as we now do
with uh
with a letter you want to read that one
so this letter is from alicia g
uh and here's a little portion of it
she says i love everything that is the
wrong size teeny tiny elephants
giant paper clips etc and while i was
living in white horse i found out that
manitoba has the most oversized
monuments and town statues of any
province it's so cool and i became
mesmerized for the back stories and
names and reasons they were built so i
did my first solo road trip around
manitoba two summers ago and saw 27 of
the official 65 big things a week after
i got back they unveiled a new one
biggest turtle known to ever be on the
earth obviously i have to do another
road trip and now i'm a super nerd about
the whole thing and have several maps of
different provinces in google maps with
layers and links all color coded and
anytime
i hear of a new one it gets added to the
map
if you're not convinced look up
alicia and the big things
on instagram and you'll see it's
actually a super cool hobby and everyone
not treasure hunting for big things in
small towns is missing out it's it is
really cool we saw it right what and
yet another example i feel like on every
episode we have a really
pretty strong example of uh why
canadians are the best
uh alicia g that is something i would
never have thought to do um but what a
what a great way to spend some time i
love that me too uh so check out
alicia's page and uh
and thank you for doing that and thank
you for listening to life is short and
also if you want to be the next alicia g
yeah uh
email us and let us know how you make
the most out of your life at uh life is
short at wondery.com
yeah exactly uh so thanks again to
alicia chi and
especially to leah t
man thank you leo
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
thank you guys for listening to life is
short if you like the show please give
us a five star review and tell your
friends to subscribe we're available on
apple podcast spotify google podcasts
and every major listening app as well as
wondry.com life is short is hosted by me
justin long produced by christian long
and megan monaco our senior producers
michelle lands engineers marcelino
viapando and it's executive produced by
marshall louis and hernan lopez for
wondering as mentioned our dear friend
harmar superstar does our theme music
[Music]
yeah you're all strapped in and it's not
i'd be a little scared but you see other
people do it that if her dad was like
we're going ziplining and you're like
yeah i'm in and he was like i'm in i
would say
yeah that's a scenario
would you play with monkeys
you were there genitals
like touch you think of monkeys in that
sexual way that you assume them and
they're just women said it was so sexual
you know would you play with monkeys
i was like would you
play what with them checkers
how do mines play play around with it
oh i can feed them that's specific how
do you play with monkeys if you don't
know them they're not good at chess but
check this maybe i meant like you know
have them jump on you and feed no it
would not even shot on me
if that's what playing is that no i
don't know i don't play with anybody
that's how different we are in that
regard right that happy monkey
was one of the best days of my life
you're insane
it was the best it was the best feeling
and they kind of they smelled great
and they they i was trying to full of
bugs oh yeah
i was at my mercy and i loved it so
awful
yeah i was but there was an hour i
wouldn't i'd rather do that than skydive
duh
i'd rather slow dance with an orangutan
than skydive oh i wouldn't that's scary
because no this guy died no but
orangutan could lose it and like smith
there's a guy the darkest
and you'd have to know who's trained and
everything not a wild yeah yeah yeah i'm
gonna have to be someone trying just to
go over to you
but i have this dance
just to learn how to do its cab
but if what if that's all they just
traded and you're like all right this
doesn't seem so bad it's like it's like
me and like
you go to grab it to dance like book
and the trainer's like oh no we're not
there yet and it's just like squashes
your head like one
meanwhile you guys are like flying
through the air like skydiving it's like
such a happy peaceful way and you know
you get used to it so fast is the best
feeling in my life
it would be so scary to go this guy that
scared
strangers in the night to dance
you